tonight we will give you a brief peek at
scenes from those films nominated for
Best Picture of 1962 they are Lawrence
of Arabia a horizon pictures limited Sam
Spiegel David lean production Colombian
produced by Sam Steven
the longest day Darryl F zanuck
productions 20th Century Fox produced by
Darryl F zanuck Meredith Willson's The
Music Man Warner Brothers produced by
Morton DeCosta
mutiny on the bounty and Arcola
production metro-goldwyn-mayer
produced by Aaron Rosenberg
to kill a mockingbird a universal
international Pakula mulligan brentwood
production universal international
produced by Alan J Pakula the winner is
Lawrence of Arabia thank you
ladies and gentlemen there is no magic
formula for creating good pictures they
are made with the Sidious concerted
artwork by everyone connected in the
making of them the writer/director
technicians actors thousands of
employees of the picture during the
making of in their behalf
on behalf of all of those who sweated
months in the desert to create this
picture I deeply sincerely think that
voters of the Academy and proudly accept
this honor in their behalf proudly and
humbly thank you very much
my job is finished now ladies and
gentlemen the rest of the evening
belongs to the stars and the winners of
the Motion Picture Academy Awards I do
thank you and good night see you next
all of the world are eagerly awaiting
the results of the award ceremonies
which you just seen so now the
excitement shifts from center stage in
the magnificent three and a half million
dollars Santa Monica Civic Auditorium to
the press section here over 500
reporters and cameramen are swinging
into action to bring tonight's story to
every corner of the globe for days these
members of the world's press have been
converging on the film Capitol in each
newsmen is a desire to catch the
wonderful feeling of glamour and
excitement that goes with this moment
here then a story is being made a story
which tomorrow and in days to follow
will be eagerly seen and heard by people
everywhere the story of the 35th annual
presentations of the Motion Picture
Academy of Arts and Sciences